President Trump got a head start on his  holiday travel he flew from the nation's  capital to South Florida Friday where  he'll be spending Christmas and New  Year's at his Mara Lago resort on the  way he signed a series of spending bills  that will keep the government running  and avoid a repeat of last year's  shutdown the measures authorized 1.4  trillion dollars in federal spending  the legislation increases federal  workers pay by an average of about three  percent it also authorizes 1.4 billion  dollars for security at the us-mexico  border that's less than this six billion  dollars the president demanded last year  during the shutdown battle it also  raises the age to buy tobacco products  from 18 to 21 the spending package is  projected to add 400 billion dollars to  the deficit over the next decade  you